So, extroversion is another dimension of personality. An extroversion involves
being comfortable with people, being sociable, talkative, outgoing and it also
involves enjoying risky, thrill seeking kinds of behavior, like driving fast,
downhill skiing and parachuting. On the other end of the spectrum is
introversion, an introversion involves, shyness, preferring to be alone, or in
small groups of people, and also wanting to avoid high-risk kinds of behaviors.
Now, some people wonder whether shyness is really a necessary part of
introversion. And let's be clear, the research and theory does suggest that
introverted people really are shy, at least compared to extroverted people.
Now, two important points. Shyness is not shyness all the time. Shy people in
fact can be very outgoing, and comfortable around people, that they know. And
secondly, shyness, is also not the same as social anxiety. It's not to be
confused. Because social anxiety is a much more debilitating, disorder, that
we'll talk about actually in later lessons.